el anuncio lo realizó el presidente de
la república durante una entrevista
concedida a Washington post desde el
Palacio de carondelette Guillermo lasso
no buscará la reelección ni le interesa
quién será su sucesor afirmó al menos
así lo expresó el mandatario ecuatoriano
luego de disolver la asamblea nacional y
convocar a elecciones presidenciales
anticipadas Guillermo lasso aseguró que
él también se iba y se dedicará a emitir
decretos ley en materia económica en los
seis meses de gestión que le quedan por
delante decretos que deberán contar con
el aval de la corte constitucional que
tendrá vigencia mientras no exista el
contrapeso legislativo y que podrán ser
renovados o derogados por el próximo
parlamento lazo crítico que se le afirme
que aplicó la muerte Cruzada para evadir
el juicio político y que según él
decidió acortar el período por el bien
del país afirmó que la decisión la tomó
una vez de estar seguro que contaría con
el apoyo de las fuerzas armadas Ecuador
va en rumbo un proceso electoral y con
ello se calienta el ambiente previo los
comicios ya se escuchan los nombres de
un ex vicepresidente un ex candidato a
la alcaldía de Quito un líder indígena y
un ex candidato a la vicepresidencia y
un ex asambleísta como postulantes a la
presidencia el Consejo Nacional
electoral tiene la obligación de
convocar a elecciones en siete días y
reunir a los Ecuatorianos en 90 días
frente las urnas tentativamente el 20 de
agosto sería la elección presidencial el
15 de octubre la segunda vuelta de
realizarse y el mes de noviembre la
posesión presidencial si este cronograma
es aprobado por el órgano comicial